if Hollywood Studios can make a
franchise out of a property you can bet
it's gonna happen some become huge hits
like Fast and Furious and John Wick but
every once in a while things just don't
work out and there's no choice but to
shut down production and move on even if
the story hasn't reached its conclusion
here are a few movie franchises that
ended before their final chapter
Aragon
before Twilight and The Hunger Games
there was Aragon based on the novel of
the same name by Christopher Paolini
released in 2006 the fantasy tale could
have been a four film series but it
ended up serving as a perfect case of a
movie doing fairly well at the box
office while being ripped apart by
critics and audiences and killing the
sequels before they started Paolini has
written four novels in his inheritance
Cycle Series which means there were
three possible sequels for Aragon and
director Stefan fangmeyer wanted to film
them back to back he told MovieWeb quote
I think one would be best off to write
the third film first and then being
happy with that going back to the second
one and doing all the setup work that
will pay off in the third then probably
filming two and three together as they
did with Pirates of the Caribbean as one
production end quote unfortunately
things didn't work out in his favor and
Aragon's failure halted fangmeyer's
directing career just as it was getting
off the ground should he ever return to
filmmaking there are a few fans of the
books who'd still love to see the
complete Eragon on Saga unfold on the
big screen
Sahara
2005 Sahara looked great on paper and
Indiana jones-style Adventure starring
Matthew McConaughey and based on a
best-selling novel by Clive Cussler it
had all the ingredients to become a
summer blockbuster unfortunately Sahara
grossed a mere 119 million dollars
worldwide despite the studio throwing
130 million dollars into the project it
was that bloated budget that ultimately
brought the action to a standstill
director Breck Eisner had hoped to
eventually Helm a sequel that once
Sahara hit the books as one of the
biggest Financial flops in Hollywood
history according to the Los Angeles
Times any chance of a sequel died with
it and with 18 novels and cussler's Dirk
hit series to pull material from
Paramount had their hands on a treasure
map marked with a big red X well you
know what they say next never ever marks
the spot
John Carter it took over 80 years for
Edgar Rice burrough's classic novel a
Princess of Mars to move from print to
screen in the form of 2012's John Carter
and the payoff was well less than
spectacular when Disney reacquired the
rights to the story The Studio hired
Finding Nemo and Wally director Andrew
Stanton to helm the film and poured over
300 million dollars into the Sci-Fi
Extravaganza clearly expecting the
classic tale to rake in boatloads at the
box office spoiler alerts it didn't the
movie was such a disaster that the head
of Walt Disney Studios Rich Ross
actually resigned his post after John
Carter's release Disney originally had
plans for the film to be the first in a
Trilogy when we started on this film we
actually wrote treatments for the first
three films based on the first three
books unfortunately since the film
flopped an interest at Disney Wayne the
rights reverted to the boroughs estate
in 2014 shooting down any hopes of John
Carter II at least with the cast and
crew of The First movie
Percy Jackson
in the late 2000s 20th Century Fox hired
Chris Columbus to adapt Rick Riordan's
Percy Jackson in the Olympian series for
the big screen Columbus was the perfect
choice for a young adult fantasy flick
after all he directed home alone and the
first two Harry Potter movies and while
Percy Jackson and the Olympians the
Lightning Thief wasn't as big as Harry
Potter it was still a moderate success
at the box office which was enough to
justify a sequel German filmmaker Thor
freudenthal came on to helm the next
installment Percy Jackson the Sea of
Monsters which saw most of the main cast
return the movie grossed almost as much
as its predecessor but somewhere along
the line the studio pulled the plug on
the third installment while Percy
Jackson actor Logan Lerman says that
fans are still hoping for a Trilogy he's
not optimistic telling Daily News quote
I think we are all getting a little old
to play those characters so I wouldn't
hold my breath end quote I Am Number
Four
although 2011's I Am Number Four grossed
nearly three times its production budget
at the worldwide box office it only made
150 million dollars apparently not
enough to justify building a whole
franchise its negative reviews surely
didn't help either the Rotten Tomatoes
critics consensus calls the movie a
derivative and ultimately forgettable
sci-fi thriller shortly after the film's
release in 2011 the film's co-writer
Marty knoxen told collider that a sequel
was put on the back burner because the
movie wasn't a big enough success at the
box office in 2013 director DJ Caruso
said he and the studios were discussing
adapting the series second novel The
Power of Six but nothing definitive ever
seemed to come out of those talks
Divergent
as the Twilight gravy train started
coming to an end Summit entertainment
looked to Veronica Roth's Divergent book
series to fill the void the young adult
dystopian series came gift wrap with a
strong fan base and the first two films
Divergent and Insurgent did well at the
box office then came the third
installment 2016's Allegiant which
completely bombed and forced the studio
to hold off on their plans for a
two-part finale stuck with a dying
franchise that demanded a huge
production budget Summit decided to
change course and conclude the series by
repurposing the final installment into a
TV series unfortunately the cast and
crew weren't on board with the idea
especially headliner Shailene Woodley
who told E news that she didn't sign up
for a TV show in February 2017 Woodley
said that she'd officially backed out of
the series making the plan sequel all
the more unlikely
Ender's Game based on the novel of the
same name by Orson Scott Card 2013's
Ender's Game was given everything it
needed to become a blockbuster which
included nabbing a heavyweight cast
consisting of Harrison Ford then
Kingsley Asa Butterfield and Haley
Steinfeld but although Ender's Game
garnered generally positive reviews it
only raked in 125.5 million dollars
against a production budget of 110
million not nearly enough to push the
film into sequel worthy territory
despite one cast member suggesting a
script based on Ender's Shadow a
parallel telling of Ender's Game story
budget constraints prevented the studio
from moving forward with their planned
franchise the studio also considered a
TV spin-off but those plans have also
petered out looks like it's game over
for Ender's Game
it's a miracle any movies ever get made
given anything can go wrong with
hundreds of people using dangerous
equipment while spending tens of
millions of dollars there are so many
variables that sometimes filmmakers have
to call the whole thing off all because
someone did something dumb here are some
movies that got canceled because of an
idiot mistake
Star Trek planet of the Titans Star Trek
was canceled after three seasons in 1969
but its popularity exploded in
syndicated reruns by 1977 the series was
set to hit the big screen with a film
called Star Trek planet of the Titans
where the Enterprise and Captain Kirk
would face off against the Giants of
Greek mythology but just before filming
was set to begin the Paramount president
Barry Diller canceled the whole thing
for a really stupid reason Star Wars was
already scheduled to arrive in theaters
that year and he didn't think fans could
like sci-fi enough to support two space
epics in the same year uh when a totally
completely misread the entire industry
Barry
Justice League mortal long before Marvel
crushed the box office with Avengers
Warner Brothers was planning its own
superhero team up in the form of Justice
League mortal which went into production
in 2007 with Mad Max Fury Road director
George Miller said to direct to film at
a budget of 200 million dollars and had
already begun rehearsing with a cast
that included Army Hammer as Batman
Megan Gale as Wonder Woman and the
rapper Common as Green Lantern just one
problem they forgot to actually finish
writing the script and before they could
get around to it the writer's Guild of
America went on strike by the time the
strike ended the actors had moved on to
other projects and the whole film had to
be scrapped whoops
Newt in 2008 Pixar announced its later
films for the coming years and among
them was a movie called nudes the plot
what happens when the last remaining
male and female Blue-footed newts on the
planet are forced together by science to
save the species and they can't stand
each other it was so far along in
production that Pixar animators left
little Easter eggs referencing Newton
Toy Story 3 such as the nude crossing
sign on Andy's bedroom door but in 2011
Fox Animation Studios released Rio which
had almost the exact same plot only with
birds instead of lizards and which had
reportedly been in production since
around 2007 one year before Newt was
announced Pixar panicked worried that
Newt would be considered a rip-off and
canceled it entirely strange they didn't
do that with Anton A Bug's Life
[Music]
okay can we stop give me Cindy on the
phone in humans it sure looks like in
humans which features Marvel characters
who are kind of like mutants but also
kind of from space would be the next
massive on-screen team for Marvel
announced for a 2018 release the film
seemed to be built up from two entire
season's worth of storylines on ABC's
Marvel's Agents of Shield but then in
humans was quietly dropped from the
schedule why there are a couple of
theories because of the disconnect
between Marvel's TV efforts and his
movie business Marvel Studios may not
have been happier at having the Inhumans
movies details dictated by a television
show with middling ratings meanwhile
rumor has it that in humans was the pet
product of Marvel CEO Ike perlmata and
when Pearl Mata was ousted from his role
at Marvel Studios in favor of Studio
president Kevin foggy foggy dumped the
film to stick it to his rival and pursue
his own Vision instead namely Captain
Marvel Captain Marvel herself
Brie Larson
well though when you think about it the
biggest mistake of all might have been
Marvel selling the X-Men movie rights to
Fox way back in the 1990s would never
have had to hear about the Inhumans
movie in the first place
a Revenge of the Nerds remake in 2006
Fox Atomic began filming a modern day
reboot of the classic 80s College movie
series Revenge of the Nerds at MRI
University in Atlanta and then school
officials actually read the script he
has actual footage from when Emerald
University's president finished looking
at the screenplay
anyway after that the college
immediately pulled out of the project
even though much of the movie had
already been filmed producers were
forced to complete the movie at tiny
Agnes Scott College when Fox Atomic
honcho Peter rice saw how Rinky Dink the
movie looked as a result he decided to
just scrub the entire thing who made the
bigger mistake Emma Roy for agreeing to
participate in the movie before reading
the script or Fox for actually caring
about production values on Revenge of
the Nerds you know karate oh no good two
sequels to Terminator Salvation in 2009
Terminator Salvation earned 371 million
dollars worldwide thanks in part to the
star power of Christian Bale as a
time-traveling robot killing Humanity
saving John Connor two sequels were
planned except the Halcyon company which
produced the movie went bankrupt even
with all that Revenue through some kind
of financial idiocy they couldn't pay
off the 39 million dollars they owed the
hedge fund pacificor in order to pay
their debt helician auctioned off the
rights to Terminator the winning bid
29.5 million dollars from pacificor nice
exit strategy come with me if you want
to live
Dumb and Dumber too he is a real what if
way back in 1998 South Park creators
Trey Parker and Matt Stone signed a 1.5
million dollar deal with new line Cinema
to write a prequel to the 1994 hit
comedy Dumb and Dumber it sounds like a
match made in heaven
so you're telling me there's a chance so
what was the idiot mistake turns out
Parker and stone didn't actually want to
do the project in the first place they
eventually gave the money back leading
new line to hire other writers for what
eventually turned out to be the
universally panned 2003 prequel Dumb and
Dumberer when Harry met Lloyd hey I like
that movie The Adventures of Fartman
Howard Stern first created a superhero
Alter Ego fart man back in 1981 and it
turned into a pre-internet meme of a
massively popular appearance at the 1992
MTV Video Music Awards
feel Luke great at great ass man
it was such a hit that new line Cinema
started production on a feature film
called The Adventures of Fartman which
screenwriter JF Lawton promised would be
just as crude and lewd as you'd expect
from a Howard Stern movie however when
Executives got wind of what Lawton was
planning they asked him to tone it down
and make it a mainstream PG-13 film
instead Stern immediately quit in
protest at the dumb request and that was
the end of fart man
oh well the queen slash Freddie Mercury
biopic comedian Sasha Baron Cohen was
once set to play the legendary lead
singer of Queen Freddie Mercury who died
in 1991. it seemed like the perfect fit
since Cohen is not only a big fan he
also Bears more than a passing
resemblance to Mercury but Cohen backed
out with the project when he discovered
that the surviving members of Queen
wanted the second half of the film to
focus not on Mercury but on how great
the band has continued to be since his
death
two more fledged sequels eight years
after Chevy Chase last played smug and
smarmy reporter I am Fletch in 1989's
Fletch lives the franchise was set to
make a comeback thanks to filmmaker
Kevin Smith Smith wanted the film to
focus on Fletcher's daughter to be
played by his then-girlfriend the Jerry
Lauren Adams but after Smith and Chase
squabbled over a plan to have Chase for
prizes rolled as Fletch the entire
project was scrapped apparently Chase
had something bad to do yeah I was just
passing through town and uh looking for
something to do this evening there was
nothing going on at The Rotary Club I
heard about this not to be the third
Smith later convinced mirror Max to buy
the rights to the franchise this time
for an origin prequel that would start
his buddy Jason Lee and wouldn't involve
chase at all but mirror Max didn't think
Lee was a big enough star and shut the
whole thing down looks like Chase had
the last laugh
the future of superhero movies seems
brighter than ever with the sheer amount
of characters in the Marvel Universe the
possibilities are endless of course not
all pitches make it to production and
many projects have fizzled through the
Journey from page to screen
a movie featuring The Inhumans was
announced by Marvel Studios in 2014 for
release in November 2018 but it seems
like a movie that Marvel Studios didn't
really want to make what happened
according to numerous reports the film
was announced during a power struggle
between Marvel Studios head Kevin feige
and Marvel entertainment chairman Ike
pearlmutter who at the time was still
overseeing the work of Marvel Studios if
you believe what's been reported as
feige side of things then the Executive
also spent a lot of time getting in the
company's way feige allegedly spent
years butting heads with pearl Mudder
over a wide variety of issues from
budget cuts to hiring decisions when he
was still working as feige's
intermediary with Disney promoter
reportedly pushed hard for an Inhumans
film to serve as the mcu's answer to the
X-Men but it wasn't meant to be after
Pearl Mudder demanded that the expensive
Robert Downey Jr be written out of
Captain America Civil War feige
reportedly threatened to quit working
for Marvel unless things changed this
apparently convinced Disney to let him
and Marvel Studios report directly to
them for filmmaking decisions instead of
having to go through Pearl Mudder and
The Wider Marvel Entertainment Company
first once this creative freedom was
secured the Inhumans movie was canceled
you should have known this day was
coming while Marvel Studios no longer
has to answer to Pearl mutter Marvel
television is a different story which is
why the Inhumans eventually ended up
landing on ABC with a remarkably cheap
looking TV show the worst reviewed
project in the entire MCU
before directing the two Ant-Man movies
Peyton Reed had plans to create a
Fantastic Four film developing his own
pitch for the project in the early 2000s
according to an interview with collider
the film was going to be set in the 60s
and be totally similar to The Beatles
film A Hard Day's Night notably his take
would have skipped the origin story
instead jumping straight into the action
Johnny
[Music]
sadly Fox didn't have much faith in the
project according to Reed it felt like
they sort of wanted to make a B Movie
out of it so we parted ways
we shall mount a musical of the
Fantastic Four
the Silver Surfer is a cosmic entity who
travels through space on a surfboard at
the speed of light that's already a
pretty weird concept so maybe it's not
too surprising that the character almost
took a left turn into the musical genre
according to Sean House book Marvel
Comics The Untold Story the Kramer
executive producer for the movie Xanadu
expressed interest in making a Silver
Surfer Rock musical during the 1980s
Kramer said of the project we're going
to make an epic picture on the scope of
2001 A Space Odyssey with a kind of
soundtrack that that film had only using
contemporary rock and roll it's even
conceivable that the surfer might have a
chance or a Fanfare made up of 1 000
electric guitars the film would have
reportedly starred Olivia Newton-John
also fresh off of Xanadu but she wasn't
the only big name attached to the
project Paul McCartney was asked to
contribute to the soundtrack a more
reasonable request than you might expect
considering that the X beetle is an
avowed Marvel fan who even wrote a song
about Magneto and titanium man
ultimately the project fell through and
we wouldn't see the likes of noran rad
on the big screen until 2007's Fantastic
Four Rise of the Silver Surfer after
that exceedingly Bland Blockbuster it's
fair to ask could the musical option
have been any good it's hard to say but
hey it couldn't have been much worse
than Spider-Man turn off the dark
made famous by Scarlett Johansson's
portrayal in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe Black Widow has become a bigger
fan favorite than ever before with a
self-titled movie on the way in 2020 but
that won't be the first time that
Marvel's tried to show audiences the
backstory of this former spy are you
kidding I'm working let's take president
I'm in the middle of an interrogation
this [ __ ] is giving me everything
though many people know David Haider is
the voice of solid snake in the Metal
Gear series he's also had a successful
career as a screenwriter in a 2014
interview with Latino Review cater
revealed that he'd written a black widow
script ten years prior and was even
attached to direct the project at one
point Hader alleged that the poor
performance of other action films
starring women in an era defined by
flops like Elektra and Laura Croft Tomb
Raider was the main factor that caused
Marvel to get cold feet and shelve the
project funny how things can change
throughout the 80s and 90s DC Comics and
Warner Brothers saw plenty of success
with Batman and Superman while Marvel
was having a tougher time but that
didn't detour one actor's aspirations of
bringing one of the company's iconic
Heroes to the big screen for the first
time in the mid 90s Wesley Snipes was
coming off a string of successful movies
and had a vision for his own superhero
vehicle an adaptation of Marvel's Black
Panther Comics but the process proved
more difficult than Snipes had
anticipated he later told The Hollywood
Reporter ultimately we couldn't find the
right combination of script and director
and also at the time we were so far
ahead of the game in the thinking the
technology wasn't there to do what they
had already created in a comic book in
the end Snipes and Marvel teamed up for
a less ambitious project blade
Play It's the day one the 1998 film
earned over 131 million dollars becoming
Marvel's first real movie success black
panther meanwhile was still listed as an
upcoming film as late as 2000 with
variety describing the project as a
vehicle for quote a black Indiana Jones
style character to which Wesley Snipes
has long been attached to produce and
star
in 2008 writer Neil Gaiman told Premier
that he had been interested in creating
a film centered around Doctor Strange
Gaiman approached director Guillermo del
Toro with the concept and according to
Gaiman he was interested in an interview
with collider Gaiman explained that
while Del Toro was on board the film was
likely around four years from entering
production due to his busy schedule I
miss the true enemy of Azar time kills
everything regarding the project Del
Toro told Empire that's an interesting
character because you can definitely
make him more in the pulpy occult
detective magician mold and formula and
was done in the weird tales for example
the idea of a character that really
dabbles in the occult in a way that's
not x-filing where the Supernatural is
taken for granted that's interesting but
I wouldn't use the suit ultimately
Gaiman and Del Toro never got to make
their version of Doctor Strange Marvel
wasn't interested in taking on the
project waiting to introduce the master
of the Mystic Arts to movie audiences
until Scott derrickson's 2016 film
starring Benedict Cumberbatch
in the early 90s James Cameron convinced
Kuroko pictures who backed Terminator 2
Judgment Day to option the film rights
for Spider-Man but after the company
went under the rights to Spider-Man were
purchased by Sony and Cameron moved on
to other projects like Sam raimi's 2002
feature Cameron Spider-Man would have
been an origin story with key changes to
the familiar Comics lore one notable
creation from Cameron's Camp was Peter
Parker's organic web shooters which
would eventually and controversially
show up in the trilogy that Sony made is
this stuff coming out of you Cameron's
script was notably more adult themed
than most takes on the webslinger would
end up being featuring an abundance of
profanity and sexuality including a sex
scene on the Brooklyn Bridge and some
truly distressing spider themed foreplay
after blade and X-Men got the ball
rolling the next Marvel comic hero to
take the World by storm was Toby
Maguire's Spider-Man the film was a huge
success earning more than 821 million
dollars it sparked one sequel that
remains beloved by fans as well as
another sequel that isn't
WTF to that despite the failures of the
third Spider-Man raymie was ready to set
the series right with a fourth rumors
swirled that the follow-up would feature
John Malkovich and Anne Hathaway as
vulture and black cat but a satisfactory
script never materialized and the
project left rhaimi's grasp as the
filmmaker later explained it really was
the most amicable and undramatic of
breakups it was simply that we had a
deadline and I couldn't get the story to
work on a level that I wanted it to work
Sony had high hopes for its rebooted
Spider-Man franchise but when it comes
to critics in box office The Amazing
Spider-Man movies were anything but
[Music]
you survive the second Amazing
Spider-Man was meant to be followed by a
villain-centric movie introducing the
team known as The Sinister Six it was
slated for release in 2016 with a third
Spider-Man movie set to follow two years
later based on the first two movies it's
hard to be disappointed that none of
this happened after the second movie
failed to establish a spidey Cinematic
Universe Sony threw in the towel
creatively and struck a deal with Marvel
Studios to get the web Slinger and the
MCU I'm Peter by the way Doctor Strange
made up names um
I'm Spider-Man then
after the first Trilogy of X-Men films
Potts tried to ship the focus from Team
movies to individual Origins but the
only mutant to actually get this
treatment was Wolverine Batman Begins
writer David S goyer was slated to write
and direct the follow-up focusing on
Magneto but when audiences actually saw
how bad the Wolverine movie was it
effectively killed the brand in one shot
was never made script draft suggests the
story that would have opened during
Magneto's time as a prisoner in
Auschwitz following him through
adulthood as he becomes something of a
Nazi Hunter before meeting Charles
Xavier this is where your power was born
thank you
and this is where your people were
slaughtered
elements of the story would eventually
form the core of X-Men first Class and
its follow-ups but on the big screen at
least much of Magneto story remains
Untold
sequels have become such Staples in
Hollywood that almost any film will get
one if the original makes enough money
with some movies however franchise hopes
are so high in advance that a follow-up
is already being put in motion long
before the flick even hits theaters
which makes the fall that much harder if
and when it flops here are some sequels
that never happened because their
predecessor picks were so poor
Independence Day three it took 20 years
for Independence Day to get its first
sequel but Independence Day Resurgence
was expected to be the first of three
planned follow-up films that would
continue Roland Emirates Alien Invasion
Story the original movie was a box
office Smash and earned mostly favorable
reviews but Resurgence turned out to be
too little too late to resurrect that
moment the movie was slammed by critics
for being an elaborate But ultimately
empty spectacle and while it wasn't an
Intergalactic bomb at the ticket booth
it's lackluster receipts didn't indicate
much audience interest in the movie or
its potential sequels either eventually
those ambitious franchise plans seem to
fizzle in the way wake of its release
maybe they shouldn't have killed off
Captain Hiller after all
there's still some hope for those who
like to see the future of the series
which would see some of its Heroes on a
new space adventure according to
emmerich he and the studio are
considering turning to the small screen
to carry out the next Independence Day
Adventure who knows maybe those crazy
aliens will find a welcome new home on
the small screen battleship 2. hopes
were very high for Battleship so high in
fact that Universal Pictures signed a
six-year deal with Hasbro games makers
of family favorites like clue and
Candyland so that they could become the
de facto board game to cinema provider
however its first big attempt was a 220
million dollar wash for the studio as
Battleship decidedly sunk with critics
and audiences alike director Peter Berg
plays Sublime on stiff competition in
particular Marvel's The Avengers but the
fact that it was derided for drowning
all plot potential in a Sea of formulaic
Action sequences didn't convince
audiences to hop aboard the ride either
Battleship was set up to be a studio
tentpole but after it was torpedoed with
bad reviews and the Dismal ticket sales
Universal quietly scuppered those plans
and several other Hasbro based picks
have been banking on have failed to set
sail as well maybe someone should have
foreseen that a boat movie by a guy
named Berg might not work out so well I
back right ahead
Divergent ascendant even the Veronica
Roth faithful were turned off by the
third installment of the Divergent book
series the trilogy's finale received
grammar reviews and his predecessors
from readers who were disappointed at
its hectic conclusion so when Lionsgate
announced to be dividing the final
adaptation installment into two films
the collective eye rolling among
Divergent fans was intense the first two
Divergent installments weren't built for
critics so it didn't matter that they
weren't lapped with praise or Prestige
they still earned enough money to
justify carrying on with the franchise
however the third film was an
unmitigated disaster on all fronts
earning laughing stock status with
critics and barely bringing in half of
what Insurgent did at the box office the
production budget on the would-be final
installment ascendant was immediately
slashed and that was just the start of
its trouble the director soon diverged
from the project and after the studio
revealed they'll turn to television to
produce a final chapter several cast
members hopped off the train as well
whether it's dystopia fatigue or simple
dislike of the source material that
caused audiences to tune out the
franchise seemed to be lost before it
could arrive at its final destination
several months after its originally
slated release date for ascendant passed
by however Lionsgate announced a new
plan to develop divergent's final leg as
a TV series on the Styles network but
without its original initiates on board
to finish the futuristic Saga it hardly
qualifies as a true sequel jumper 2
based on the Stephen gold novels jumper
was a Sci-Fi Extravaganza that was
clearly supposed to do more with a
promising young cast and open ending and
a frenetic story that could easily be
continued in New Adventures it had
franchise hopeful written all over it
despite a tepid bugs off has taken
terrible reviews lead actor Hayden
Christensen claimed the sequel plans
were still in development with the
studio even two years after the
original's release according to him the
sequel would have followed its Heroes to
a darker Place Leap Forward a decade
though and 20th Century Fox is
officially out of the jumper movie
business director Doug Lyman has since
managed to transport the property to
another local hour for a reboot sequel
produced by YouTube Red however instead
of continuing on with christensen's
character's Journey based on the second
book reflex the new series will be
adapted from the third novel in the
series impulse this installment focuses
on his eventual daughter instead of him
meanwhile actor Jamie Bell has taken it
upon himself to start up another small
screen reboot based on the property
which may or may not feature him in his
original role from the 2008 film
did you think you were the only one so
while jumper might have built a launch
pad for separate projects whatever
launch plans they had for jumper 2 have
obviously failed to clear the hurdle The
Power of Six the piticus law novel
series upon which I Am Number Four was
based was wildly popular when the first
film dropped and in an era when young
adult adaptations were all the rage and
actor Alex pettifer was considered the
up-and-coming heartthrob the film was
expected to launch a full-on franchise
for DreamWorks the Sci-Fi Adventure told
the story of powerful alien teens who
are being hunted into Extinction and
would have been followed up with Theresa
Palmer leading the power of six but
after the first film drew the iref
critics and the disinterest of audiences
the sequel was ultimately shelved
screenwriter Marty nuxen told collider
that result was regrettable because
number six was really awesome and they
would have liked to have seen a lot more
of her we need another Kick-Ass girl
heroine considering how underwhelming
Thor turned out to be maybe they should
have just skipped ahead to the next
number in the first place show Girls 2
given Showgirls States us as one of the
most widely derided movies of all time
it may be hard to believe that could
have ever been a sequel according to
director Paul verhoven however Elizabeth
Berkeley was supposed to take another
turn on the stripper pole before the
movie's terrible reception left her
career in tatters he told movie site Joe
Blow we had already been working on the
sequel to show girls which was going to
be called bimbos and was going to beat
no media's Hollywood but after Showgirls
was released there was no way anyone was
going to give me the money for that if
we could just make Elizabeth Berkeley 20
years younger now I would love to make
bimbos today considering how she seemed
to time travel right back to high school
for that mini Saved by the Bell reunion
in 2015. it's probably not an age
that'll keep bimbos from ever happening
The Capes Crusaders ongoing film Saga
ranks among the top 5 highest grossing
movie franchises in the United States
but he's also faced his share of
setbacks along the way for every bat
Blockbuster that made its way to
theaters there's a take on the character
that's unceremoniously died in
development here's the history of every
one of those canceled Batman movies the
Batman getting Tim Burton's 1989 Batman
onto the big screen was a difficult
process ten years before Michael Keaton
made his Dark Knight debut produces
Benjamin belnicker and Michael uslan
acquired the film rights to Batman so
they could adapt the character in the
same vein as Superman they wanted to
have a definitive dark version of Batman
on film and produces John Peters and
Peter Gerber agreed when they boarded
the project in November 1979. four years
later the script by James Bond and
Superman screenplay co-writer Tom
mankiewicz simply titled the Batman and
was completed focusing on Batman and
Robin's Origins with the joker as the
central villain while the Batman slash
007 version of that man would have been
awesome the project went through
multiple developers and producers losing
bits and pieces along the way in the end
the studio hired Tim Burton to direct
who felt the treatment was too similar
to Superman and would be a better fit
for a TV series he changed virtually
every aspect of the movie so while they
didn't get everything they wanted the
producers still got their darker version
of Batman on the Silver Screen
it just took a decade to make it happen
Robin's spin-off when Chris O'Donnell
joined the franchise as Robin for 1995's
Batman Forever he seemed poised for a
long run as the character he returned
for 1997's Batman and Robin and planned
to reprise his role in a possible fifth
film but that never came to fruition
Warner Brothers also briefly pursued a
robin spin-off which O'Donnell confirmed
as recently as 2012. as he told Access
Hollywood they were going to do a robin
movie back in the day then Batman and
Robin were such a bomb they were like
scrap that that was the end of that
Batman Unchained Joel Schumacher told
variety that he'd always planned to make
three Batman movies but unfortunately
for everyone involved in Schumacher's
bat Saga Batman and Robin tanked sending
the franchise into years of development
hell and leaving that third movie
unrealized the problems weren't just at
the box office however Akiva goldsman
who wrote the screenplays for
Schumacher's first two bat flicks opted
not to return for the next installment I
Am Legend screenwriter Mark protesovich
took Goldman's place and came up with
the name Batman Unchained which focused
on scarecrow as the central villain
Schumacher wanted Nicholas Cage to play
the fear-inducing bad guy saying that he
owed the world quote a real Batman movie
but Batman and Robin crashed and burned
taking Batman Unchained with it changing
course completely Warner Brothers
started looking into the idea of making
up Batman Beyond all Batman year One
film instead
Batman Dark Knight Ryder's Lee Shapiro
and Stephen wise had an idea for a full
bat reboot this time instead of Batman
and Robin in their primes the duo wanted
to see Batman retired with Dick Grayson
attending college in the proposed film
Dr Jonathan crane better known as the
Scarecrow still played a prominent role
as a professor of psychology at Gotham
University also appearing Dr Kirk
langstrom who turns into the Monstrous
Man-Bat the two doctors get into a
confrontation and crane accidentally
initiates Kirk's transformation into his
bat-like form after seeing Man-Bat
terrorize Gotham and that the city's
residents are mistaking him for the real
Batman The Dark Knight comes out of
retirement to clear his name the darker
idea was pitched to the studio but after
being passed through multiple levels of
approval and a few confirmations from
producers the studios director of
development passed on the movie Batman
year One Schumacher still wanted to give
Batman fans a proper Caped Crusader and
his planned adaptation of Frank Miller's
Batman year One might have fulfilled
that goal ultimately the studio parted
ways with Schumacher and went with
Requiem for a Dream director Darren
Aronofsky instead after hiring Aronofsky
the studio bolstered the Project's
pedigree further by bringing Frank
Miller himself on board to script in an
interview with IGN Aronofsky urged fans
to quote toss out everything you can
imagine about Batman everything we're
starting completely Anew unfortunately
the studio didn't get into Miller's
version of the script so they hired the
wachowskis of Matrix Fame to write a
treatment again the studio wasn't
satisfied so they tender Josh Whedon
whose take also didn't pass muster with
the studio they finally ended up
shelving the idea altogether in 2002
Batman Beyond Warner Brothers also
floated the idea of making a Batman
Beyond film inspired by the hit animated
show which had debuted in 1999. Bruce
Tim and Paul deeney's series featured
Terry McGuinness a teenager who takes
over the mantle of Batman under the
guidance of a retired Bruce Wayne the
Studio's movie division liked Batman
Beyond so much that they wanted to make
a live action version for the big screen
they hired Remember the Titans director
bohas yakin to helm the project with
deeney writing the script sources told
Variety in 2000 that a Batman Beyond
film didn't interfere with Warner
Brothers plans to continue with a fifth
Batman movie but that changed quickly by
August 2001 deeney said that the studio
had shelved the live-action adaptation
what's more later that year the Batman
Beyond animated series was canceled
Batman vs Superman Asylum long before
Zack Snyder's Batman vs Superman dawn of
Justice hit the big screens Warner
Brothers previously had plans to pit the
DC Universe his two biggest Heroes
against each other Andrew Kevin Walker
who penned the incredibly dark seven
pitched an idea that involved Batman
coming out of retirement shortly after
his wife's death to join a recently
divorced Superman until of course
they're duped by Lex Luthor into
fighting each other sound familiar Akiva
goldsmen returning to the franchise once
more revised Walker's script in 2002
which was enough to convince Warner
Brothers to move forward with the
project
at least for a little while
Wolfgang Peterson director of Air Force
One and the never-ending story intended
to direct the film in 2002 but the
project was derailed when JJ Abrams
jumped into The Fray with a script for a
movie called Superman flyby which
included a very different version of the
Man of Steel according to Peterson the
studio decided to try separate versions
of Superman and Batman instead resulting
in Superman Returns and Batman Begins
Justice League mortal now the DC EU is
giving all of the Justice League's many
Heroes their own films before bringing
them all together but at one point
Warner Brothers had plans to dive
headfirst into a Justice League movie
written by Kieran and Michelle Mulroney
Justice League mortal was to be helmed
by Mad Max director George Miller its
cast included DJ katrona is Superman
Army Hammer is Batman Megan Gale as
Wonder Woman Adam Brody as the flash
common is Green Lantern and Tere Palmer
as Talia al Ghul with Jay baruchul
playing the villain Maxwell Lord cameras
were ready to roll but the writers
strike of the late 2000s put a damper on
the movie The overwhelming success of
Christopher Nolan's The Dark Knight
convinced Warner Brothers to pursue
individual films instead making Justice
League mortal the Justice League movie
that never was so many watching Ben
Affleck throw down with Carl Drogo just
think about how much crazier it would
have been if the director of Mad Max had
gotten to the league first
oh what a day what a lovely day
from Iconic Jedi to devious mutants to
Legendary action heroes Hollywood
history is Awash with canceled origin
stories but why were these projects
shelved and did we really need them in
the first place today X-Men Origins
Wolverine is a widely derided punchline
one whose largest Legacy is inspiring
the radically different creative
Direction the franchise took for the
Wolverine and Logan initially however
there were Plans by 20th Century Fox to
use this project as a way to kick off a
whole series of X-Men Origins movies
Wolverine was the first mutant to get a
prequel Adventure but there were
originally plans for Magneto to headline
a feature in the series too in April
2007 it was announced David Esquire was
to helm a Magneto movie building off a
script penned by Sheldon Turner of
course Magneto wasn't a surprising pick
for those familiar with the Original
Trilogy of X-Men movies
Not only was he a prominent part of
those films but he also has a very
well-known origin story filled with more
than enough drama to hold up an entire
superhero flick the project even got far
enough to inspire original portrayer Ian
McKellen to express interest in
returning to the role in some capacity
however growing interest in a potential
X-Men first Class movie LED Fox to
change directions taking many of the
ideas dreamed up for the Magneto movie
and incorporating them into an ensemble
prequel film peace was never an option
the negative critical reception to X-Men
Origins Wolverine was simply the last
straw for Fox's X-Men Origin series
the internet is largely aware of the
unmade Hellboy 2 the Golden Army
follow-up Hellboy 3 a passion project
for director Guillermo del Toro that's
never found proper financing less
well-known is another extension of the
Hellboy franchise that was once proposed
at the start of the 2010s rather than
pursuing Hellboy 3 distributor Universal
Pictures wanted to kick off a whole
series of movies entitled from the files
of the bprd referring to the government
organization that employs Hellboy and
his Supernatural Chums screenwriter
Peter Briggs explained on Facebook that
this series would have kicked off with a
prequel film chronicling the earlier
exploits of the Golden Army villain
Prince nuato this project would have
gone back in time and follow nuada long
before he fought Hellboy as he navigated
various major real world conflicts this
movie was actually an active development
on two separate occasions with universal
showing great interest in the project
both times however Briggs revealed that
it was unceremoniously canceled once the
29 19 Hellboy movie was announced
leaving Prince nuada's prequel in the
dust
when Disney first bought lucasfilm the
company's bigwigs decided they wanted to
produce more than just a new Trilogy of
Star Wars films they also planned to
expand the franchise into a series of
spin-off movies called Star Wars stories
the first of these Rogue one dropped in
2016 and was a roaring success but the
Anthology movie approached to Star Wars
was paused when the second installment
solo underwhelmed financially at one
point however this master plan was set
to include a solo movie for none other
the Jedi Master Yoda in August 2017 The
Hollywood Reporter revealed that a movie
based on Yoda was being contemplated by
lucasfilm brass no further details ever
emerged on this proposed Yoda movie such
as the potential creative team or what
the story might have involved given that
Yoda has lived for hundreds of years in
the Star Wars Universe there are untold
amounts of stories that this potential
feature could have covered however the
ensuing decision to table future
Anthology films made a Yoda or film
redundant as did the mandalorians focus
on the character of grogu
2007's Fantastic Four Rise of the Silver
Surfer debuted the first ever big screen
version of the Marvel Comics icon known
as the Silver Surfer portrayed by Doug
Jones physically and Lawrence Fishburne
through voiceover his appearance in the
Fantastic Four sequel was just the
beginning of a long lasting cinematic
career for the surfer 20th Century Fox
even sought to spin this incarnation of
the character off into his own Solo
movie The Studio had long been
interested in launching Silver Surfer as
a solo franchise with Andrew Kevin
Walker working on a screenplay as far
back as July 2000 however it took Rise
of the Silver Surfer to really get the
gears moving in February 2008 less than
a year after that film's release
screenwriter J Michael strzinski
revealed at a WonderCon panel that a new
Silver Surfer film would explore the
character's Origins and feature the
debut of a Comics accurate version of
Galactus over Thanksgiving 2009
reached out to IGN personally to reveal
that his version of the Silver Surfer
was on pause thanks to Fantastic Four's
disappointing box office performance
but he also noted that a new take on the
surfer's story was in development this
incarnation of the project never went
forward either however thanks partially
to Fox shifting its focus to a full-on
reboot of Fantastic Four and we all know
how that went say that again
it's fantastic
yes it is after a Good Day to Die Hard
took the Die Hard movies to a whole new
low in terms of critical reception it
seemed like it was time to drastically
shake up the franchise such a bold move
emerged through a project entitled
McLean which was meant to explore John
McLean's Life as a cop in the 1970s the
idea was to introduce a younger version
of McLean though the film wouldn't
entirely do away with the previous
installments either producer Lorenzo di
bonaventura told Empire we are gonna
explore John McLean in his twenties but
just as prominent is the 60 year old
version with this story structure firmly
established updates on the screenplay
for McLean emerged as late as 2019 but
the Disney Fox merger saw every title at
20th Century Fox thrown into chaos
including McLean by July 2021 the news
had come down that the movie was no more
but Aventura has explicitly blamed the
Disney Fox deal for the production's
demise leaving this origin story as
little more than a fantasy of die hard's
most die-hard fans
the Rambo franchise really does seem
impossible to kill thanks to 2008's
Rambo and 2019's Rambo last Blood
Sylvester Stallone's iconic character
has stuck around even through the
changing movie landscape of the 21st
century hot on the heels of last Blood
Stallone revealed that he'd figured out
a way to keep the character going for
just a little longer via a prequel
chronicling the early years of John
Rambo during an interview with screen
rent Stallone mentioned that he hoped a
ramble prequel might eventually happen
and continued I always thought of Rambo
when he was 16 or 17 that he was the
best person you could find he was the
captain of the team he was the most
popular kid in school super athlete he
was like Jim Thorpe and the war is what
changed him if you saw him before he was
like the perfect guy despite Stallone's
enthusiasm for this project there have
been no further updates on a Rambo
prequel part of that is likely due to
the global box office performance of
Rambo last blood which came in below the
worldwide gross of its predecessor and
with this apparent lack of momentum it
could be that Rambo's enduring big
screen presence has finally come to an
end
in that long period between Superman 4
the Quest for Peace and Superman Returns
Warner Brothers went through countless
concepts for what a new Superman film
could look like one of those proposed
projects was Superman flyby which would
have once again tackled the famous
origin story of the Kryptonian superhero
the production started under the
stewardship of Brett Ratner before
transitioning over to McGee with both
filmmakers sharing a goal of relaunching
the character for a new era of superhero
movies for a moment this cursed
production seemed to be moving along too
until variety reported that it suddenly
wasn't the disruption occurred when
McGee stepped down from the project
Empire reported creative disputes
between McGee and Warner Brothers were
to blame for this development with these
issues culminating in a disagreement
over where to film the movie McGee would
later clarify that it was specifically
his fear of flying that clashed with
Warner Brothers desire to film in
Australia leading to him losing out on
the gig eventually Brian Singer would
step in to direct Superman Returns which
went in a radically different direction
with the story not only by skipping a
retelling of Superman's Origins but also
in creating a spiritual sequel to
Richard Donner's 1970s take on the
character
in the wake of Batman and Robin's
critical and financial failure Warner
Brothers decided to take the Batman
series in a brand new Direction holy
hotspot specifically the studio was
interested in a gritty new origin story
hiring Darren Aronofsky in 2000 to
direct a film adaptation of the Frank
Miller comic Batman year One aiming for
an R rating and developing its own
storyline rather than slavishly devoting
itself to the comic Batman year One was
shaping up to be a unique chronicling of
Batman's first few months as a crime
fighter unfortunately by 2002
aronofsky's take on year one had been
passed over by Warner Brothers brass in
favor of a proposed Batman and Superman
movie another element that led to the
demise of year one was dispute
overcasting Aronofsky wanted Joaquin
Phoenix to inhabit the lead role while
Warner Brothers chose Freddie Prince Jr
for the part ironically while Batman
year One fizzled out a gritty take on
Batman's early days as a superhero would
eventually be told by Christopher Nolan
with 2005's Batman Begins not to mention
the Batman the next adaptation of The
Capes Crusader which borrows heavily
from Batman year One Channing Tatum's
name has been thrown around for the rule
of Gambit for well over a decade but in
the 2010s he finally got serious about
developing a Gambit movie in 2015 Tatum
told Empire that the first draft of the
screenplay had been completed and that
it would take a subversive approach to
the superhero origin story though things
sounded promising Gambit took a
discouraging detour when director Rupert
Wyatt Departed the project shortly
before filming was set to begin from
there the project was plagued by
multiple release date delays and saw
both Doug Lyman and Gore verbinsky
stepping into the director's chair only
to later leave by January 2019 Tatum's
commitment to the project was taken to a
new level when deadline reported that
the actor was interested in directing
the troubled production himself
unfortunately Tatum never got the chance
to even Lobby Gambit's origin story in
March 2019 Disney closed its purchase of
the film's distributor 20th Century Fox
which handed the character back to
Marvel Studios two months later Gambit
was officially dead bringing Tatum's
Relentless pursuit to an unhappy end
Universal was so convinced that its 2017
Take On The Mummy would successfully
springboard the so-called Dark Universe
franchise that the studio greenlit a
second installment right of Frankenstein
the movie was to be directed by Bill
Condon who previously helmed a movie
about original Bride of Frankenstein
filmmaker James whale called Gods and
Monsters this new take on the origins of
that famous monster was rumored to Star
Angelina Jolie as the titular creature
with Javier Bardem officially signed on
to portray Frankenstein's monster while
the project assembled some Buzzy lead
actors this new Bride of Frankenstein
soon hit an insurmountable roadblock the
exceedingly disappointing box office
returns delivered by the mummy
immediately cast a dark shadow over the
whole Dark Universe four months after
the mummy debuted the start date for
Bride of Frankenstein was delayed and
the project was sent straight back to
developmental two years later Condon
revealed to collider that Universal's
trepidation over the budget and scope of
Bride of Frankenstein also contributed
to its cancellation Now condon's movie
and the dark universe as a whole appears
to be very much dead and buried
[Music]
it takes a lot of hard work and good
luck to get a movie made but all of that
can be ruined in an instant with just
one bad decision sometimes it doesn't
matter how good the story is or how
famous the stars are because a single
moment of stupidity can wash it all away
here's a look at some promising movies
that were canceled because of a really
dumb decision
at the mountains of Madness the
Masterwork of horror and science fiction
author H.P Lovecraft at the mountains of
madness has long been a passion project
for horror Artur Guillermo del Toro and
Del Toro seems like the perfect fit for
the tale of a group of scientists who
discover ancient terrifyingly powerful
entities in Antarctica unfortunately
despite James Cameron producing an
interest from Tom Cruise Del Toro
couldn't get funding from Universal
because he told them it would be R-rated
meaning the teens who usually flock to
horror movies wouldn't be able to see it
the project was canceled and Del Toro
later said he should have lied to
Executives and told them that at the
mountains of Madness would be PG-13
Halo
there were a lot of dumb decisions that
led to the demise of the proposed Halo
movie Mostly because Microsoft
apparently had no idea how Hollywood
Works they demanded a huge cut of
profits and forced Studios to jump
through hoops to even have a chance to
read the script plus they wouldn't let
Sony bid on the film at all because
Sony's Playstation is one of Microsoft
Xboxes Chief video game console
competitors despite all that nonsense
Fox and Universal were both still
interested and teamed up but then they
made the final dumb decision in this
whole dumb process when Universal hired
up-and-comer Neil blomkamp to direct
blumcamp was a fan of the game with the
distinct artistic Vision the problem is
only Universal wanted him both Fox and
Microsoft reportedly hated what he was
doing wanting instead to make what the
director called a generic boring film
something like GI Joe or some crap like
that ultimately the only thing that came
of it was some test footage that teases
the great Halo movie that could have
been and bloomcamp he went on to make
District 9 instead great job Microsoft
Uncle Tom's fairy tales
in 1968 Richard Pryor wrote and starred
in an extremely dark socially conscious
movie with the intentionally
controversial title Uncle Tom's fairy
tales the movie for homosexuals Pryor
supposedly became so obsessed with
making the film his wife reportedly
destroyed the negative of the then still
unfinished movie in a fit of rage nearly
four decades later another print of the
film emerged thanks to director Penelope
spheris but so far it hasn't been
released either for legal reasons
ponyang based on geed allele's intense
graphic novel about the struggles of
living under the totalitarian regime in
North Korea Hong Yang was supposed to
start shooting in early 2015 with Steve
Carell in the lead role and Gore
verbinsky as director then Sony decided
to release the interview in 2014. that
reportedly led to the infamous hack of
the Sony servers in retaliation not to
mention bomb threats against theaters
that screen the interview new Regency
decided Pyongyang wasn't worth the
hassle and canceled the film entirely
The Beatles version of Lord of the Rings
J.R.R tolkien's the Lord of the Rings
books rank among the most beloved novels
of all time first published is three
separate volumes in 1954. it took until
2001 for Peter Jackson's epic live
action adaptation to hit movie theaters
but there was an earlier version
proposed in the 1960s and it would have
starred The Beatles yeah those beetles
besides doing a brand new double album
soundtrack The Beatles were set to star
in the live-action adaptation with Paul
McCartney as Frodo Ringo Starr is
Samwise George Harrison is Gandalf and
John Lennon is Gollum
unfortunately Tolkien was in a Beatles
fan and he decided to Nix the idea
otherwise both music and cinematic
history would have been completely
different and much much weirder
every major Studio has these projects
that they were extremely excited about
once only to drop them before they ever
hit the big screen and Universal
Pictures is no different from ambitious
sequels to forgotten comic book movies
to a whole canceled Universe these are
the Universal movies we'll never get to
see
everyone can agree that Cowboys are
awesome as are ninjas as well as Vikings
well some Geniuses thought what if they
were all combined into one wonderful
megatrope that's the rough idea behind
the graphic novel Cowboy ninja Viking by
AJ Lieberman and Riley rosmo the story
is about a psychotherapist who can
transform into multiple secret agent
personas that take the form of a cowboy
a ninja and a viking Chris Pratt had
signed on to Star as the good doctor and
Game of Thrones and Breaking Bad
director Michelle McLaren would have
made her feature film debut working from
a 65 million dollar budget with a script
they'd been written at various stages by
guys who'd worked on rampage The
Hangover 2 and Deadpool
the film had a projected release date of
June 28 2019 and it looked to be a fun
action comedy and a likely Blockbuster
but just as casting was ramping up
Universal pulled the movie off its
schedule and called off production
delaying the film indefinitely according
to an Insider the film had some
screenplay issues and rumors of calling
the whole thing off bounced around for
five months before Universal threw in
the towel according to a report by wired
in 2017 Halo publisher Microsoft
aggressively tried to get a film version
of its Mega popular video game series
going in 2005. the software giant took
bids from interested Studios and
ultimately the only two parties left
vying for the right to make Halo or Fox
and Universal who decided to team up and
split the likely enormous production
costs of making a Sci-Fi combat film at
first things were going just fine Halo
got a screenplay by 28 Days Later writer
Alex Garland and District 9 Creator Neil
blomkamp signed on to direct and that's
when the clashes with the studio began
he thought he could make a cool
cyberpunk type movie while he said
Executives wanted a quote generic boring
film with the parties so deeply at odds
Halo fell apart after the release of the
unnecessary but successful Jaws 2 in
1978 and the success of the full-length
Disaster Movie parody airplane in 1980
John producers David Brown and Richard
zanek wondered if the same rapid-fire
joke format could be applied to the Jaws
franchise they contacted Maddie Simmons
publisher of iconic 70s Humor Magazine
National Lampoon and The Man Behind the
brand that released Animal House Simmons
decided to be a producer too and the
three guys set out to make Jaws 3 or as
they hilariously called it Jaws 3 people
Zero The Producers pursued Joe Dante to
direct as he just helmed Jaws knockoff
called piranha and they got regular
Lampoon contributors Todd Carroll and
John Hughes to write a very silly script
ultimately Xanax and brown were afraid
to go into the water as they didn't
think it would be the best idea to so
thoroughly mock their meal ticket in the
end Universal did make a third Jaws
movie 1983's non-humorous and famously
bad jaws 3D who but Guillermo del Toro a
modern Visionary of the spooky and
surreal could adapt a classic work of
terrifying science fiction by the
legendary H.P Lovecraft at the mountains
of Madness is a 1931 Novella about
scientists who discover the ancient and
frightening alien mutants who live
within Antarctica and making it into a
movie has long been a passion project
for Del Toro because of his proven track
record along with interest from Tom
Cruise and James Cameron Universal
similarly thought that at the mountains
of Madness just might make a great movie
and the studio paid for Del Toro to come
up with some creature designs what the
studio didn't like was del Toro's
projected budget of 150 million dollars
on a project that would most definitely
earn an R rating for its violence and
general scariness thus limiting its box
office drop by shutting out teenage film
goers Del Toro ultimately blamed himself
saying that he quote should have lied to
Universal and just told him that he'd
shoot for a PG-13 ending so as to get
them to Green Light the movie it remains
a tantalizing missed opportunity and Del
Toro has vowed that he's not giving up
on trying to get it made
former bodybuilder and California
governor Arnold Schwarzenegger first
proved that he could headline a movie
with the release of the Epic 1982
fantasy Conan the Barbarian in the film
Schwarzenegger takes the classic heroes
Journey as a mighty muscle-bound
sword-carrying warrior out to avenge the
death of his parents crush your enemies
see them driven before you and they hear
a lamentation of the women
the film was a surprise hit earning 39
million dollars at the domestic box
office indicating a big appetite for a
sequel Conan the Destroyer followed in
1984 and brought in similar revenues for
Universal a third movie in the series
finally got underway about 30 years
later Chris Morgan screenwriter of
multiple Fast and Furious films came on
board with a solid premise for a film
about an older Conan and Schwarzenegger
was excited by the project however
Universal had a number of concerns that
Morgan and others working on the project
couldn't overcome the project remains in
limbo but in 2019 screenwriter Chris
Morgan told The Hollywood Reporter that
he still had hopes of bringing the old
man Conan movie provisionally titled the
legend of Conan to theater someday
before Marvel and Disney assembled to
launch the Marvel Cinematic Universe the
comics publisher contracted with various
Studios to bring its superheroes to the
big screen Universal landed the rights
to The Incredible Hulk and with Hulk in
production in late 2002 the studio was
so confident that it made agreements to
make two more Marvel movies the comic
Giants movie division announced that
year that Universal would be tackling
one of their oldest characters Namor the
Submariner and one of their newest Prime
the task of bringing the Epic story of
Submariner and amphibious King from
Atlantis to the screen fell to David's
self best known for scripting the film
Road to Perdition meanwhile the duo of
Chris Conroy and Don collame got the
prime gig which concerned a teenaged boy
who could turn into a full-grown
superhero seeing as it's been roughly 20
years since these films were announced
during which time Marvel found itself a
home at Disney Submariner is likely dead
in the water and it's no longer Prime's
time of course that doesn't mean they've
been entirely forgotten there's still a
chance that Submariner in particular
could show up in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe sometime very soon
Who Framed Roger Rabbit ushered in a new
era of projects that mixed live action
with animation and helped bring on the
music video for Paula Abdul's Opposites
Attract the song is a duet and the male
voice is credited to the wild pair a
singing Duo consisting of Bruce the
Shazer and Marv Gunn but in the video
those vocals are synced up to the
flapping mouth of an animated cat named
M.C Scat Cat the clip proved so popular
that Virgin Records gave MC Scat Cat and
His expanded universe of cool feline
friends including fats taboo Maestro Leo
Kathleen and silk a spin-off album in
1991 called MC Scat Cat and the Stray
mob while the video for the single scat
strut performed well on MTV it's stalled
at Number 96 on the Billboard Hot 100.
that lack of public interest is likely
what killed development of more MC Scat
Cat related multimedia projects see at
the peak of this minor Mania virgin
music and Universal Pictures discussed a
big screen MC Scat Cat movie that would
have Blended live action and animation
it never got past the planning stages
and neither did a proposed MC Scat Cat
Saturday morning cartoon for Fox
after Disney launched the Marvel
Cinematic Universe and Warner Brothers
created the DC extended Universe
Universal realized it could have its own
interconnected film series too
remembering that it made classic monster
movies in the 1930s including Dracula
Frankenstein The Invisible Man and Bride
of Frankenstein among other Classics
Universal decided to reboot and Link
those films together in 2014 Universal
announced that filmmakers Alex kurtzman
and Chris Morgan would lead the project
which the studio ultimately named The
Dark Universe in 2017 along with that
news Universal said it would produce
Bride of Frankenstein directed by Bill
Condon and scheduled for release on
February 19 2019. that would be followed
by movies with Javier Bardem as
Frankenstein's monster Johnny Depp as
the Invisible Man and Russell Crowe is
Dr Jekyll and Mr Hyde
is a doorway
the past cannot remain buried
forever
and none of these movies happened
why well blame the mummy this early Dark
Universe entry earned Savage reviews and
a so-so money losing 80 million dollars
at the domestic box office a few months
later kurtzman and Morgan left the Dark
Universe and the studio postponed Bride
of Frankenstein from its 2019 release
saying in a statement that the film
needed quote more time to develop
nevertheless in January 2019 Universal
proclaimed that the Dark Universe was
over but said that it would continue to
develop some of those monster movies
into Standalone films in early 2020 we
saw the first fruits of those labors
when the Invisible Man starring
Elizabeth Moss arrived in theaters to
positive reviews and a strong box office
[Music]
for every sequel that successfully
clawed its way into movie theaters
there's an unmade take that wowed on
paper but floundered in development the
Predator franchise has seen more than a
few proposed sequels Hit The Cutting
Room floor and we break them down right
here the concept of pitting Xenomorphs
against predators first appeared in the
Anthology comic book series Dark Horse
presents in 1989. a year later Predator
2 further indulged a showdown with an
Easter egg of a xenomorph skull in a
predator trophy case but the Alien vs
Predator concept didn't make Earnest
moves toward the big screen until 1991.
when future Hellboy co-writer Peter
Briggs penned a spec script Briggs
initial draft titled the hunt Alien vs
Predator adheres closely to the original
Dark Horse comic penned by Randy
stradley taking place off world and in
the future breaks script focuses on a
clan of predators who use planets seated
with xenomorph eggs as hunting grounds
as a challenge their leader includes a
queen Facehugger in the batch of eggs
Unleashed on a jungle Planet as you'd
imagine this does not go well in 1992
aliens magazine reported that Roland
emmerich was attached to direct though
nothing came of it Emerick and his Cree
creative partner Dean Devlin were
especially keen on the idea of the
Predator alien hybrid only hinted at in
Briggs draft Fox effectively shelved the
project in 1993 after producer Joe Roth
left the studio in 2002 producer John
Davis rejected a treatment penned by
James demonico and Kevin Fox on the
basis that he wanted to set the film on
Earth and move away from the Dark Horse
Comics
at the end of Predator 2 an Elder
Predator rewards Mike Harrigan with a
trophy
the gift is an antique pistol engraved
with the inscription Raphael adolini
1715. it's a memorable moment that hints
at just how long the Predators have been
terrorizing our planet
it also raises a whole swath of
questions that it turns out were
intended to find answers in a sequel
that never materialized as director
writer Duo Jim and John Thomas note in
the Predator 2 director's commentary
they were constantly toying around with
the idea of a predator film set on Earth
in a time before modern weapons the
brothers have said
we played around on the set with doing
something historical like in a time
where you had nothing but steam engines
and flintlocks and you were up against
something like the Predator that could
be fun the brothers brainstorming
sessions never materialized into
anything concrete and yet while we were
robbed of a big screen Predator period
piece that didn't stop Dark Horse Comics
from picking up the Thomas Brothers
enticing engraved pistol and running
with it published in July 1996 and
written by Henry Gilroy Predator 1718
tells the story of Raphael Adeline his
pistol and how the predators in Predator
2 came to acquire it set in the Bermuda
Triangle the comic paints Adeline as a
pirate Captain suddenly faced with a
rebellious crew and an unlikely alien
Ally
before earning his first screenwriting
credit on 2010's Predators Alex litvock
worked at 20th Century Fox in the 1990s
he's talked about how the Studio's
attitude at the time was that you
couldn't make another Predator movie
without the original film star Arnold
Schwarzenegger responding to this
limitation litvock pitched a sequel that
envisioned the triumphant return of
Schwarzenegger's major Allen Dutch
Schaefer litvox pitch took place
directly after the events of the
original Predator as the script tells it
the whole Affair from the first film has
been classified and Dutch is living out
his days in Exile then a predatorship
crashes at a remote location and the
government Taps Dutch to lead a Sprite
team of Commandos to investigate
when they finally reach the ship a group
of predators emerge with one target
Dutch he's the one that got away and
they've come back to claim their prize
as litvock explains the pitch was a
pointed attempt to seduce Schwarzenegger
whether litvox proposed script even made
it to the actor is unclear in any case
the studio resolved that Schwarzenegger
was still off the table and the pitch
never saw the light of day while waiting
to work on Desperado in the early 1990s
Robert Rodriguez wrote a script for a
third Predator film an unconfirmed copy
of his script has since made the rounds
on the internet and it is to put it
mildly completely bananas
The Story begins on an alien planet
where a group of humans outfitted in
Predator armor attack a Spanish Galleon
the cloaked attackers overwhelm the ship
and transport their captive Dutch from
the first film to a prison planet the
planet also happens to be a gladiatorial
training ground for teen Predators
replete with among other things human
alien hybrids Rodriguez approached
Arnold Schwarzenegger about returning to
his original role as Dutch supposedly
there was even a role in the script
written for Jean-Claude Van Damme
Rodriguez's script would ultimately
morph into 2010's Predators thanks to an
extensive overhaul by Alex litvock and
Michael Finch however at the time Fox
passed on the script because Rodriguez's
sequel was simply too ambitious and
expensive while working on 2007's Aliens
vs Predator Requiem as a visual effects
consultant Liam O'Donnell drafted a
sequel treatment O'Donnell's idea for
Aliens vs Predator 3 took place on a
future Earth ravaged by climate change
where mankind has reverse engineered
Advanced Interstellar travel with
technology recovered from Predator
weapons however the fuel that powers
this space-faring Tech is derived from a
rare mineral only found in southern
Africa the last continent free from the
vice grip of the Weyland yutani
Corporation the warming of the planet
causes the release of the original Alien
vs Predator Queen from her icy tomb and
the film ends with a third act three-way
fight between a Predator alien and human
the treatment was ultimately scrapped
for two reasons first as O'Donnell puts
it after the addition of the Predator
home planet to Requiem there was an
assumption that if they did a third
movie it had to be in space second upon
its release Aliens vs Predator Requiem
failed miserably at the box office
basically scrapping any hope for a
sequel in 2015 Vincenzo Natali tweeted a
slew of concept art for among other
things a tentative Predator reboot the
visual pitch offers a brief glimpse into
what we could have seen an expression
jungle war zone a sleek and spiky
predator and a brutal gladiatorial
Showdown Natalie pitched his take on
what would ultimately become Predators
with nothing but a log line Predators
hunt humans on their Planet Natali has
elaborated on his visual treatment when
I was called into pitch there was
nothing there was no script there was
only the notion that this was going to
take place on a predator Planet I think
there was a dangerous game aspect to it
with humans being hunted by Predators I
met with Robert Rodriguez and some
Executives and I just did a whole bunch
of drawings nothing ever came from that
bunch of drawings and that's a shame
because the idea of the director of Cube
and splice taking a stab at a predator
movie sounds like a match made in sci-fi
horror heaven in 2010 director Nimrod
antal and producer Robert Rodriguez
revitalized the franchise with Predators
an action-packed sequel set on an alien
planet turned hunting ground the honor
obsessed aliens use a planetary game
preserved to test their abilities
hunting down humans as well as creatures
from other planets by the end only two
survivors remain as the pair catch their
breath at the end of the film a new hunt
begins and our heroes realize that they
have to escape
now
let's find a way of this planet despite
its obvious sequel setup a predator's
follow-up has yet to materialize which
makes co-writer Alex litvox enticing
proposal for a direct sequel in absolute
knife twist litvock has described his
pitch for Predators 2 as die hard on a
predator ship in lit Vox sequel Royce
and Isabelle let the Predators catch
them they are then brought aboard the
ship that the aliens use to transport
people to the planet they break out of
their cells and as they attempt to seize
control of the ship Die Hard In Space
ensues eventually Our Heroes make it
back to Earth and then per litvac we
land and realize it's the future all
along we thought this was happening now
but what if these guys have been on ice
for 300 years the hatch opens and the
Space Marines come in this move would
have once again merged the alien and
Predator franchises Under One Roof as
litfock tells it although 20th Century
Fox was enthusiastic his proposed sequel
never got off the ground
sometimes a movie's production just goes
so off the rails that the most Humane
thing the filmmakers can do is to pull
the plug
these are some previously announced and
greatly anticipated movies that reached
the end of the line in 2019 over the
course of nearly 20 years the X-Men
movie franchise placed its ensemble cast
of mutants in different points across
various timelines Wolverine was the
first character to spin off into his own
sub-franchise with X-Men Origins
Wolverine the Wolverine and Logan for
years Fox tried to get more Standalone
mutant movies off the ground starting
with a proposed Origins follow-up
focusing on Magneto though this project
was eventually reworked Into The
Ensemble prequel X-Men first Class the
other solo x movie that's come close to
being a reality is one about Remy LeBeau
AKA Gambit the louisiana-born staff
wielding mutant who's notably Adept at
throwing explosive playing cards Gambit
is a fan favorite having been a main
character in the 90s Saturday morning
X-Men cartoon he even made a brief
appearance in X-Men Origins Wolverine
are you Remy Lebow
do I owe you money no
[Music]
no
I am
Fox stacked the deck for the film's
chances by casting likable bankable
Channing Tatum in the title role but the
studio just couldn't get this movie into
play thanks to a seemingly never-ending
search for the right director to helmet
Gambit had been shuffled around a couple
of 2019 release dates but the ongoing
director search left its viability in
question as 2019 began Fox had Gambit
scheduled for release in March 2020.
despite not having a director actively
attached then Disney acquired Fox
throwing the smaller Studios whole slate
of projects into disarray in May 2019
the new bosses moved around the release
dates for a bunch of movies including
Gambit the Tatum vehicle went from a
March 2020 release to currently nothing
disappearing from the schedule
the enduring Star Trek big screen
franchise flew high for decades after
focusing on the characters from the
original 1960s TV series the movies
shifted Focus to the world of Star Trek
the Next Generation ultimately
sputtering out when the 2002 entry Star
Trek Nemesis grossed 43 million dollars
the worst ever showing for a Trek movie
it took the Visionary sci-fi mind of J.J
Abrams to revive Star Trek movies for a
new generation Reviving well-known
old-school characters like Kirk and
Spock to create three fun and
contemporary blockbusters
Star Trek Star Trek Into Darkness and
Star Trek beyond the last one earned 158
million dollars in the summer of 2016.
enough to Merit a fourth entry Paramount
announced the project at cinemacon 2018
with S.J Clarkson attached to direct
Zachary Quinto was reportedly up to
reprise his role as Spock and Chris
Hemsworth may have returned to having
played Captain Kirk's father George in
2009 Star Trek not immediately on board
however was Chris Pine the guy that
plays The Fairly important role of
Captain Kirk Pine and Paramount couldn't
come to an agreement on a contract and
the same issue occurred when trying to
sign Hemsworth the studio ultimately
canceled the entire movie
amidst the 21st century zombie craze
that gave us the Walking Dead and Pride
and Prejudice and Zombies came World War
Z based on the novel by Max Brooks the
movie starred Brad Pitt as a globe
trekking military aligned Hero trying to
stop the zombie hordes running all over
the world with their insatiable Lust For
flesh the film ended with a hopeful-ish
ending and it grossed a whopping 202
million dollars at the North American
box office ensuring a sequel World War
Z2 seemed more promising than any other
unnecessary sequels if only because
seven and Fight Club director David
Fincher was reportedly on board to
direct there were vague rumors of a 2019
release date and according to the
playlist Paramount did everything it
could to get the ball rolling but it
never officially gave the thing the
green light everything fell apart and as
of February 2019 World War Z2 crawled
back into the grave
sequels and prequels are common movie
conceits but crossover movies not so
much the most prominent modern mashup of
two established properties on the big
screen is probably Alien vs Predator
Sony hoped to pull off a Face-Off of its
own with two of its hit comedy Brands
Men In Black and Jump Street news of
this proposed film hit the streets via
the 2014 Sony hack in one leaked
document Studio co-chair Amy Pascal
floated the idea and in an email jump
Street's Jonah Hill called the idea
quote clean and rad and Powerful Sony
continued to develop the idea and at
cinemacon 2016 announced that the film
would be titled mib-23 and that James
bobbin would direct but just a few
months later Hill seemed to find the
project neither rad nor powerful he told
the Toronto Sun
I doubt that movie will get made the
jump street films were so fun to make
and the whole joke of them was that they
were making fun of remakes and sequels
and reboots and then now it's become a
giant sequel reboot in January 2019 MIB
producer Walter Parks admitted it was
all over telling Empire quote we gave it
a shot he went on to explain that the
whole thing turned out to be a quote
impossible matchup
while Disney owned Marvel preceded full
steam ahead with its Marvel Cinematic
Universe Sony remained determined to
hold on to their movie rights to
Spider-Man the MCU solo Spidey stories
starring Tom Holland are co-productions
between Sony and Marvel but Sony has
also been focusing on spin-offs centered
primarily around offshoot characters in
Spider-Man's corner of the Marvel
Universe among those films are the
oscar-winning animated feature into the
spider-verse the hit Venom starring Tom
Hardy and the upcoming morbius with
Jared Leto portraying the living vampire
whatever the heck that is there was also
a proposed Endeavor called silver and
black that film would showcase The
Adventures of not one but two Spider-Man
Side characters mercenary silver Sable
and cat burglar black cat you look good
been working out oh
I mean you know a little
in May 2017 Sony signed up Gina Prince
blythwood to direct and charged ahead
for a February 2019 release date that
changed in June 2018 when the studio
altered its theatrical debut date to no
date at all there had been a few
problems along the way primarily that
shooting hadn't yet begun one of the
main problems reportedly was that the
director didn't like the shooting script
no screenplay and no release date
usually imply a movie is dead but that's
not exactly the case here shortly after
silver and black lost its Street date
Sony announced that it would instead
make two separate movies one silver one
black hey the more the merrier right
filmmaking is incredibly complicated and
there are countless ways a project can
go off the rails sometimes permanently
these movies made headlines when they
started their development but didn't
manage to come to fruition at least not
yet here are the real reasons these
movies were canceled in 2018. Imagine a
movie that combined Cowboys ninjas and
Vikings starring Chris Pratt and the
lead role as the cowboy ninja Viking
sounds fun enough right well it wasn't
meant to be based on a 2009 limited
series from Image Comics Cowboy ninja
Viking was announced by Universal
pitchers in 2017 and then delayed
indefinitely in August 2018. only a
month before production had been set to
start Pratt was slated to play the main
character Duncan a super soldier with a
personality disorder splitting his
identity into three distinct power sets
it was originally set for release in
June 2019 with a budget of around 65
million dollars but was reportedly
plagued by Script issues which helped
lead to its collapse according to the
Hollywood Reporter rumors of the film's
impending shutdown flew around Hollywood
for months meaning it wasn't too much of
a surprise that the movie didn't come
together even if it's disappointing for
fans of the comic Supernatural goth
comic adaptation the crow hit theaters
in 1994 and it feels like Hollywood has
been trying to remake the movie ever
since but every time it starts to come
together the project hits a wall a
revolving door of actors has been
attached or been rumored to be attached
to the role of Undead Avenger Eric
Draven which was first made Popular by
Brandon Lee The List includes Tom
Hiddleston Alexander Skarsgard Luke
Evans Jack Houston and more and that's
not even getting into all of the
potential directors who have come and
gone production was finally set to begin
in 2015 before the bankruptcy a
production company relativity media shut
the project down by late 2016 financing
had reportedly been secured for another
attempt with Jason Momoa in the lead
role and the nuns Corey Hardy in the
director's chair in March 2018 variety
reported that Sony was setting a release
date for The Crow for October 2019. just
over two months later deadline broke the
news that Momoa and Hardy had moved on
not long after that Sony took the movie
off its schedule Neil blomkamp made a
huge impression in 2009 with his debut
feature the Sci-Fi Parable District 9.
while he's since produced two more
full-length movies with Elysium and
chappie he also makes short films with
his company oats studio in 2017 the
company made a 27 minute short called
Firebase set during the Vietnam war and
focusing on some American soldiers who
experienced some very freaky occurrences
they wouldn't die
after the short was released online it
was announced that the studio planned to
adapt it into a full-length feature if a
crowdfunding drive was successful enough
long story short it wasn't in April 2018
oats Studio tweeted the news that the
longer version of Firebase was dead and
that all contributors would have their
money refunded as they wrote in their
since deleted message unfortunately we
didn't raise enough to do something
truly awesome we would rather over
deliver than create an average film we
thank the thousands of people who did
back us two decades after the mysterious
slain of the Notorious BIG Hollywood
decided to offer their take on the case
with the movie city of Lies based on
Randall Sullivan's book Labyrinth the
film stars Johnny Depp as LAPD detective
Russell Poole who takes a second look
into Biggie's death 20 years after the
fact Global Road Entertainment planned
to release city of lies to theaters on
September 7 2018 even releasing trailers
for The seemingly finished film but the
rollout was abruptly canceled about a
month before release no exact reason for
the cancellation was revealed at the
time but it might have something to do
with Depp's very bad 2018. just a few
weeks before the release was canceled
city of Lies location manager Greg Rocky
Brooks filed a lawsuit which alleged
that Depp had verbally and physically
abused him on set while appearing
intoxicated earlier in the year Depp
also faced allegations of domestic abuse
from his former wife actress Amber Heard
on September 6 2018 Global Road
Entertainment filed for bankruptcy
meaning city of Lies will likely spend
the foreseeable future being stuck in a
vault foreign
ever wonder what a live-action Troy
McClure movie would have looked like how
about Mrs Doubtfire too keep your eyes
on the screen to learn about these cool
projects and others that nearly got the
green light
Phil Hartman had a superpower he could
make anything funny take for instance
Troy McClure his iconic role in The
Simpsons you might remember this
character from The Planet of the Apes
musical he starred in the clip shows he
hosted or The infomercials he attached
his name to hi I'm Troy McClure you may
remember me from such nature films as
earwigs ew and Man vs nature the road to
Victory do any of those sound hilarious
in concept not so much are they gut
bustingly funny when depicted by Phil
Hartman absolutely before Hartman was
murdered he was part of early talks for
a live-action Troy McClure film most
accounts indicate that Hartman himself
pushed the idea and that many Simpsons
staff writers were on board including
Matt Greening tragically Hartman was
killed by his wife before any of this
could take place graining had flirted
with the idea of a live-action Simpson
spin-off before in 1994 he and Michael
Whitehorn completed a pilot script for a
show that focused on Krusty the Clown it
never got off the ground but thankfully
this was not due to anyone's death
following his trial for child
molestation in 2005 Michael Jackson
spent the next few years away from the
spotlight he slowly rehabilitated His
Image but also desperately needed money
as such in March of 2009 he announced
this is it a year-long residency at the
O2 Arena in London starting that July
when I say this is it it really means
this is it less than a month before the
first show however Jackson died of acute
propofol and benzodiazepine intoxication
at the age of 50. AEG live who promoted
the concert decided to make some money
off of the event anyway they put
together a documentary concert film
titled Michael Jackson's This Is It
which was released theatrically in
October 2009 while some fans were
dismayed by what they saw as Shameless
profiteering they were massively
outnumbered by those who saw the film
which made 261 million dollars worldwide
the documentary was surprisingly low-key
limited by the fact that its footage is
entirely from rehearsals in the wake of
Jackson's shocking death however that
was more than enough to make it into a
hit
Sam Kinison was killed near the peak of
his popularity by a drunk driver this
sudden and tragic loss sent shock waves
through the comedy world he left behind
a series of classic stand-up albums TV
guest spots and music video appearances
he also had several projects lined up
that were ultimately canceled including
one with Arnold Schwarzenegger Bill
kinnison Sam's brother and business
manager revealed in 2009 that the
comedian had signed a deal with new line
Cinema for three movies shortly before
his death one would have been a
straightforward concert film one would
have been a movie with Rick Moranis and
one would have been a truly star-studded
Affair of this last film Bill kinnison
shared it was going to be Schwarzenegger
Beverly D'Angelo Christina Applegate and
Corey Feldman the movie was about Sam as
convict and it's an adopt a convict
thing he comes and lives with you to
help him straighten out his life and all
that alas it was not to be the movie was
shelved following canison's death
the death of Robin Williams shocked the
world the comic giant left behind a
stunning Legacy as well as four in
production films that were eventually
released there was however one project
that went unfinished the sequel to Mrs
Doubtfire
attempts at a Mrs Doubtfire sequel date
back to at least 2001. both Robin
Williams and Chris Columbus repeatedly
turned down scripts they found
uninspiring as Williams said Mrs
Doubtfire being unmasked in the original
movie made a Repeat Performance
difficult but a sequel was finally
announced in April of 2014. Williams was
set to Star Columbus was signed on to
direct an elf screenwriter David
berenbaum would script it of course
Williams 2014 death put an end to the
movie
Training Day a TV sequel to the 2001
Denzel Washington film of the same name
was set to become a headlining CBS
series
Bill Paxton starred as detective Frank
Roark alongside Justin Cornwell as
officer Kyle Craig just a few weeks
after the series premiere however Paxton
died of a stroke following open heart
surgery he was 61. Paxton had shot all
13 episodes of training day's first
season prior to his death allowing it to
air as planned the show saw a small
raiding Spike after he died but reviews
weren't spectacular and its audience
dwindled as the weeks wore on between
low ratings lackluster reviews and the
death of the show's biggest star CBS
chose not to recast the Rourke role and
pulled the plug after one season
Hollywood spent much of the 1980s and
the 1990s trying to bring Mordecai
richler's novel The incomparable attack
to the Silver Screen a fish out of water
story about a Canadian Inuit adapting to
life in the big city the screenplay
simply titled a tuck went through many
stars so many in fact that it is now
believed to be cursed John Belushi was
the first star attached to the role and
was by some accounts whose screenwriter
Tom Carroll had in mind when writing the
script Belushi's death in 1982 put an
end to that years later producers
reached out to John Candy who was
interested but died while still studying
the script overtures were made to Chris
Farley though he too died shortly after
expressing interest to this day the film
has never been made while his death
didn't cancel the project it is also
worth noting that Sam Kinison was cast
in 1988 and actually shot a scene he
later took issue with the script and
left resulting in a breach of contract
lawsuit he died young as well whether or
not the curse claimed him is up to you
River Phoenix died in the middle of
shooting the American Dutch Thriller
dark blood leaving the project canceled
and unfinished that might have been the
end of it for most films but director
George slizer had other plans in 2011 18
years after Phoenix's 1993 death slizer
revealed that he still had the dark
blood footage worried that his work
would be destroyed splizer swiped the
negative from the insurance company that
was threatening to destroy it to avoid
storage costs from there he re-edited
the footage into something approaching a
finished film slicer announced that he
had stayed in touch with the Phoenix
family and that he planned to ask
Joaquin Phoenix if he'd be willing to
redub some of River's lines in response
the entire Phoenix family made their
disinterest explicitly clear they wanted
no part of this somehow slicer still did
it in dark blood premiered at the 2012
Netherlands Film Festival
Chris Farley's public Persona as Brash
and Goofy was at odds with his true self
a gentleman self-conscious about his
size and unhappy with being Typecast not
long before he died he was hard at work
on a biopic about silent movie star
Roscoe Fatty Arbuckle the project had
promise and could have expanded his
career Beyond clowning but it wasn't
completed before he died Arbuckle was
one of the first True Hollywood stars he
was a gifted physical comedian and
remarkably agile for his size but he was
privately insecure and resentful of his
girth Arbuckle is best remembered today
for being accused of the rape and murder
of silent film star Virginia repay he
was exonerated after three trials so
much so that the jury of the last trial
apologized to him regardless his career
was effectively over Farley knew this
role could change his career his
obsession with the movie endured through
the haze of his addictions to the point
that some colleagues believed it to be
an unhealthy fixation ultimately he
never got clean and died of a drug
overdose in 1997.
John Kennedy tools A Confederacy of
Dunces is an iconic work of American
literature as such attempts to adapt it
to the screen are many yet none of them
have come to fruition John Belushi was
the first actor cast in the lead role of
Ignatius J Reilly a day or two before he
was supposed to finalize his involvement
he died of a drug overdose years later
another attempt at adapting Dunces was
made John Candy was courted for the lead
role until he too passed away ditto
Chris Farley who is considered for the
role of Ignatius until his 1997 death
brought talks to an abrupt end
Natalie Wood's enigmatic death by
Drowning is a landmark Hollywood tragedy
she didn't just leave behind an enduring
mystery she also left behind at least
two projects that went unfinished a few
weeks after she died actor Timothy
Hutton said that he and wood had
purchased the film rights to Barbara
warsba's book country of the Heart the
book tells the story of a Teenage writer
Who falls in love with a famous novelist
dying of cancer her death stopped the
project before it could ever start the
novel has since faded Into Obscurity
wood was also a few months out for
making her stage debut she was working
on Anastasia a play about the tragic
Russian princess set to debut at the
Amazon theater in Los Angeles Tony
winner Arvin Brown was attached to
direct with rehearsals to start in
January 1982 and opening night scheduled
for the following February development
of the show ended upon her death
[Music]